parkinson's disease is one of the  neurodegenerative disease  which leads to  death of the dopaminergic neurons  the signs and symptoms can be remembered  as trap which involves tremor rigidity  echinacea and postural instability  and the pathological hallmarks include  lewy body formation and the loss of  dopaminergic neuron from the substantia  [ __ ] substantia [ __ ] is a region which  is densely packed with dopaminergic  neuron which appears black because due  to neuromelanin but in parkinson's  patients there is a reduced appearance  of substantia niagara because death of  the dopaminergic neuron punch line is  dopaminergic neurons die  treatments option include dopamine  reuptake inhibitors or putting levodopa  from outside but there is no cure for  this disease watch the full video to  know more